after seven months nearly 500 interviews
and 300 written submissions australia's
sex discrimination investigator painted
a toxic picture of workplace misconduct
over half that is 51 of all people
currently in commonwealth parliamentary
workplaces have experienced at least one
incident of bullying sexual harassment
or actual or attempted sexual assault
the investigation was triggered by rape
allegations made by a parliamentary
staff member
this report exposed a culture of
bullying and sexual misconduct declaring
that one in three staff in federal
parliament had experienced sexual
harassment
on top of this kate jenkins says the
problem is largely driven by power
imbalances
gender inequality and a failure to
protect victims who speak out there is
also a worryingly low level of reporting
indicating that it's not safe to speak
only 11 of people who'd experienced
sexual harassment in a parliamentary
workplace reported their experience
the australian prime minister was quick
to respond
he called the report shocking and says
there's a need for higher standards in
australia's federal parliament
like anyone who works in this building i
i find
the
statistics that are presented there of
course appalling and disturbing
i wish i found them more surprising
but i find them just as appalling
the prime minister is now under pressure
to act on the recommendations including
better protection for those victims
willing to speak out
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia
well let's bring in michelle o'neill
she's the president of the australian
council of trade unions she joins us now
from melbourne michelle this really goes
to the heart of working culture in
parliament i know alcohol has been
identified as one of the drivers and
many have also criticized the lack of
women in senior roles in your mind what
are the factors that have been driving
this kind of behavior
well the first thing to say of course is
that parliament as a workplace is a
high-risk workplace but it's also the
case that it's a microcosm of many other
workplaces all around australia and in
fact the world and what this inquiry
found is that fundamental to
the high levels of harassment assault
and bullying was power imbalances and
particular gender inequality so the fact
that
it is a power fueled workplace um adds
uh turbocharges if you like what is
already what we know behind many cases
of harassment and of course inequality
which is the imbalance of power between
women and men the majority of cases of
uh harassment and assault and bullying
were experienced by women but not solely
by women so there is
an issue that's a systemic issue within
our parliament house but also within all
of our workplaces well we just heard
scott morrison there say that he wasn't
terribly surprised by these findings now
if that's actually the case why hasn't
something been done sooner
well that's exactly the question for
scott morrison because uh his government
commissioned the inquiry into sexual
harassment across all workplaces in
australia
more than two years ago they received
the report that was done by the sex
discrimination commissioner the same
person that has done this report into
parliament house
and kate jenkins at the time had made 55
recommendations
that were comprehensive that were about
what needed to change in changing the
law as well as in behaviour that would
mean that women were safe at work and
that all workers were safe and instead
of implementing all 55 of those
recommendations the government did
nothing for more than 12 months until
there was a public exposure of an
allegation of rape within parliament
house and then women across australia
took to the streets in marches in march
of this year's march for justice
movement and it was only in response to
those many thousands of women and their
supporters taking to the streets that
the government finally responded to the
first report but instead of implementing
it they in fact chose the really low
hanging fruit they only implemented some
of the weakest elements of the
legislative changes and not the core
ones that will make the difference they
failed to implement the legal change
that would make employers responsible
for preventing sexual harassment which
is where we need to go
michelle given the history here that
you've just described for us are you now
confident that the recommendations of
this new report will actually be
implemented
no i'm not at all confident about that
because we have a history now of a prime
minister and in fact a government that
talk is cheap they often talk about
being concerned about safety of women
and safety in the community and safety
in workplaces but when it comes to the
crunch about using their power and their
capacity to make laws and change the
culture as well as people's rights they
back away from it so we are very
concerned that again there'll be lip
service paid to this rather than the
urgent changes that are needed i mean
this is disgraceful one parliament
should set a standard that uh is the
highest possible standard as a workplace
it shouldn't be a high risk workplace it
should actually be an example for others
to follow but instead we see the
opposite and we see
this is entrenched not just in the power
imbalances that i spoke about before but
also in the conditions of work that are
systemic there and around our country so
one of the other things the commissioner
found was the impact of insecure work
and when you have growing incidences of
jobs that are casual contract and
insecure that makes harassment violence
in the workplace and gender inequality
worse and this government has made
changes that have worsened women's job
in security and job insecurity generally
in our country
michelle o'neill the president of the
australian council of trade unions great
to get your expertise and thoughts with
us on al jazeera thank you for joining
us michelle
thank you very much